what was it that got you into sort of
acting and like you know just like what
was it that you felt like i this is what
i need this is what i'm going to
gravitate towards or i'm i'm good at
this am i am i quick-witted there's
something about me that's different that
i think i could be successful about this
for with this yeah um
yeah well no i mean i i was always just
a [ __ ] funny idiot at school you know
um i was like
like a uh i was like like a weird kind
of stunt man like fall off a wall or i'd
run into a garage door or i'd do a big
stunt on my bike or
and i was cheeky and funny and
you know just that everything you do to
try and cover up being lonely as a child
right uh and afraid
and but i was funny you know i
i lived up when i was like 18 19 i lived
in
palestine for two years and i made
people laugh and i was good at it and i
was a and i was a waiter for years and i
was really good at that so i was
funny and smart and i made loads of tips
and
and i never honest to god never wanted i
never thought about
not once did i get to a point of
thinking oh [ __ ] what am i going to do
you know i just never
i just never thought like that really
not like i didn't see it i just never
thought my parents never pushed them
right they never said oh now you need to
go to college or you know
i left school at six six just sixteen
i'd turn so
and then went to work at a company
um like a shipping company selling
containers
um
i was always the funniest
[ __ ] you know right and i think it was
only when i was at
chiquito's mexican bar and restaurant
that i kind of met simon and and
i never realized i never knew stand-up
was a thing
i i'd never i mean i had seen films but
i didn't know what cinema was
right you know i didn't know
you could get paid for telling jokes or
telling stories or being funny being in
it you know
and so i met simon and
we just made each other laugh just
all the time as you know it was just
and he said you why don't you go try and
do some stand-up
and so i thought yeah well [ __ ] it let
me yeah let me
let me do that you know
and i did 12 gigs
and
uh
six were amazing
and six were like the lowest point of my
life
yes
i think i'd rather bury my mum again
they were just really bad you know
and it just wasn't for me i just felt
like it wasn't
i didn't know why you know i never
realized that i just wanted to be great
immediately because i can make everyone
laugh in the pub yet right
i can't do that i don't know how to do
this i didn't realize it was
a fierce skill and you know you you you
do it for years before you get to it
right and you didn't want to spend the
years with your add you couldn't spend
years to get good at it you're like i'm
not taking this time
uh yeah no um also it was
like suffering with anxiety of being
around loads of people and
it took a lot out of me you know i was
like
i'd have a big headache afterwards and i
just didn't like it because i was
thinking about it all day and i felt
like
that feeling you get before i've been
going to have a shot you know i was like
oh my god
you know i hated it just feeling like
you have to take a [ __ ] all the time the
nerves you have to take it [ __ ] as
you called it once a yankee long
you know yes but you know that's the
thing
yeah it's like i've just been spent the
day eating steak and cake and then
having to push that out of me
and you feel like that all the time just
performing and getting on stage at 11
o'clock at night i know i've done it too
i did stand up for about i probably did
it for about almost a year and every
time i go why do you put yourself
through this and then all of a sudden
you hear the applause
because i love that but i hate
everything up to that i hate everything
up to the point of actually everyone
laughing
the whole day just feels like [ __ ]
i'm nervous i have to be great i i put
too much pressure on myself
well i still have that now before every
acting gig i've ever done um
i will be up all night shooting myself
and being sick and
just being [ __ ] frightened of of
you know i think it's changed now but
but now it's about a fear of
failure you know a fear of
not knowing my dialogue and
[ __ ] the production up and everyone
hate you know what i mean